ja so ist es es geht nämlich um die
Landtagswahl vorhin hatten wir den
Spitzenkandidaten aus Hessen
robert-lampruh und jetzt ist bei uns
Katrin Ebner Steiner sie sind die eine
der beiden Spitzenkandidaten in Bayern
für die Landtagswahl am 8
oktobersteiner wie schwierig ist
eigentlich die
Lage der AFD in Bayern sie haben da ja
einen Ministerpräsidenten der durchaus
in populistischen Besteckkasten wühlen
kann
hatte das Gefühl dass der AFD auch da
kaum Platz zum zum Atmen
dazu kommt ja auch noch dass die CSU im
Moment in Berlin der Opposition ist und
richtig vom Leder ziehen kann inwieweit
belastet dass ihre Ambitionen ihre
Strategie
naja also wir haben in Bayern nicht so
sehr viele Probleme weil die Bürger
wissen dass wir Politik für unsere
bayerischen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
machen es ist so dass wir jetzt laut
aktuellen Umfragen bei 14 Prozent stehen
die Freien Wähler sind bei 11c super 38
denke mal unser Hauptproblem ist Hubert
Aiwanger weil er einerseits in der
Regierung ist aber Opposition spielt und
dies das muss man entlarven auf jeden
Fall
guter ist ein gutes Stichwort es ist ja
das ist eine richtige Konkurrenz für sie
da mit Hubert Aiwanger der ja neulich
gesagt hat bei einer grundgebung die
Bürger Bayerns sollten sich die
Demokratie zurückholen der Satz könnte
auch von einem
afd-politikerin sein oder einem AFD
Politiker das heißt da haben sie große
Probleme überhaupt sich gehört zu
verschaffen
deshalb verstehen die Herr verkauft sich
als AFD Leid ist in der regierungsspiel
aproposition genauso war sie auch mit
der impfdiskussion da hat ja Huber
Hubert Aiwanger auch etwas gehordert hat
sich so als Bad Guy verkauft Söder war
gut geil aber ich denke die bayerischen
Bürger und Bürger wissen was los ist in
Bayern zum Beispiel dieses bayerische
Klimaschutzgesetz wurde auch
verabschiedet mit dem Stimmen der Freien
Wähler und das sind ja die Maßnahmen
noch restriktiver als in der
Bundesgesetz wir haben jetzt im
Wahlkampf angekündigt sie wollen die
Flutung Kultur fremder Einwanderer
verhindern in Bayern jetzt war
unbenommen dass es in der Tat
illegale Einwanderung in Deutschland
gibt nicht zu wenig das sehen auch viele
andere weit über das AFD Lager hinaus
aber diese Wortwahl ist die wirklich so
klug wenn man denkt wir brauchen ja auch
Zuwanderer und Einwanderer wegen des
Fachkräftemangel schauen sich
Dienstleistungen Landwirtschaft Handwerk
Pflege an
stößt das nicht Leute die wir eigentlich
brauchen ab wenn sie mit solchen
Begriffen kommen die irgendwie
Ausländerfeindlichkeit auch auch
implizieren niemand also dieser
Rechtsmissbrauch der seit 2015 in
Deutschland und in Bayern
vorhanden ist die muss einfach ein Ende
gesetzt werden und die AFD ist bekannt
dafür auch dass man mit markigen
Sprüchen durchzusetzen wir wollen
natürlich auch qualifizierte Zuwanderung
das heißt wenn jemand qualifiziert ist
wenn er bei uns arbeitet wenn er Steuern
zahlt dann ist der herzlich Willkommen
bei uns aber die meisten Asylbewerber
die derzeit hier sind die liegen uns auf
der Tasche und das wollen wir nicht wir
wollen das Geld lieber für unsere
bayerischen Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ausgeben dort kam eine Statistik raus
die veröffentlicht worden ist dass die
Hälfte aller Einwanderer aus dem Jahr
2015 Stichwort Flüchtlingswelle
inzwischen soweit sehr arbeitsfähig sind
in Lohn und Brot stehen also da hat doch
Integrationen in den Arbeitsmarkt auch
durch diese Einwanderung geklappt ja da
liegen wir andere Zahlen vor dass aus
dem Kopf als ob
Asylzentren die zu uns gekommen sind
dass über 80 Prozent immer noch keine
Arbeit haben das und es muss auch legale
Migration sein es kann nicht sein dass
jemand illegal zu uns ins Land einreißt
es muss alles legal sein um wir wollen
auch nicht dass so viele kulturfremde
Einwanderung hier bei uns sind wir
wollen die Menschen vor Ort unterstützen
wir wollen Asylzentren in Afrika in
anderen Ländern aber nicht hier bei uns
in Deutschland es gab konzidiert das ist
illegale Einwanderung gibt das habe ich
ja gar nicht in Zweifel gezogen meine
Frage war ja sie wollen ja ins
bürgerliche Lager vorstoßen ob solche
Begriffe die Sie verwenden wie Flut und
Kultur fremder einwander nicht dieses
Lager dass hier eigentlich für sich
gewonnen gewinnen wollen dass das
eigentlich abgestoßen wird von der AFD
da würde ich Ihnen vorschlagen kommst du
mal mit mir auf dem Infostand und hören
Sie mal was die normalen Leute zu ihnen
sagen werden das sind alles ganz normale
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die immer SPD
gewählt haben CSU und frei Wähler die
Bürger in Bayern die haben in anführ
natürlich in die Schnauze voll die
wollen diese illegale Einwanderung nicht
mehr und wir sind Ihr Sprachrohr im
Bayerischen Landtag gut Bayern ist
Bayern wirklich ein
erfolgsversprechendes gerade gesagt
Thema Migration verglichen mit Thüringen
und Sachsen wo die AFD ja richtig gut da
steht sie haben gesagt 14 Prozent oder
13% sind im Moment dass sie mit Abstand
geringste Umfrageergebnis für die AFD
bei einer bevorstehenden Wahl auch in
Hessen sind es wesentlich mehr ist das
wirklich so ein erfolgsversprechendes
Terrain wenn sie gerade also auch mit
Themen die Migration arbeiten die
vielleicht in Sachsen Thüringen relativ
gut laufen aber in Bayern eben viele
nennt jetzt zwar Bürger mit denen sie
gesprochen haben aber viele
Möglichkeiten doch abstößt
man muss sie konzentrieren dass in
Bayern die Freien Wähler sind es in
Hessen nicht so die stehen bei uns bei
11%, und von daher bin ich eigentlich
schon im Moment sehr zufrieden mit
unserem Ergebnis wir haben natürlich
noch weitere Themen das wäre die
Inflation dann ähm Thema Heizung Thema
günstige Energie das sind alles Dinge
die die Menschen belasten und da steht
die AFD auch für eine Bürger neue
Politik das kann man sagen dass die
ampelparteien in Berlin ihnen da auch
die Munition liefern bei den Themen die
sie da gerade genannt haben
selbstverständlich
um die Munition für uns das was in
Berlin passiert ist einfach nur ihre man
muss auch sagen Söder ist schuld daran
dass wir jetzt eine links-grüne
Regierung haben mit den Angriffen damals
im Wahlkampf auf Laschet Söder ist
schuld dass Bayern und Deutschland in
dieser desaströsen Lage ist gedacht dass
ich habe gesagt Munition wird geliefert
das heißt die AFD muss eigentlich gar
nichts tun die kann die Hände in den
Schoß legen und zugucken wie die anderen
ihr Geschäft betreiben die AFD tut was
wir hören zu wir sind viel auf dem
Marktplätzen wir machen Infostand wir
hören die Menschen zu was Ihnen auf dem
Herzen liegt und wenn sie wenn sie mal
dabei sind wenn sie sich das mal ansehen
wie verzweifelt die Menschen zum Teil
sind weil sie die Gasrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen können oder letztens war ein
Kind im Bayerischen Landtag berichtet
wir wissen nicht mehr meine Eltern wenn
wir Samstags beim Einkaufen sind wir
wissen nicht mehr wie mir die Einkäufe
bezahlen können und so weiter solche
Probleme sind jetzt auch bei uns in
Bayern wir haben hier Menschen die
müssen Flaschen sammeln das ist
erbärmlich und sowas darf in dem
eigentlich reichen Bayern nicht sein
oder wenn wir jetzt sehen ob die AFD das
irgendwann mal ändern kann
wahrscheinlich werden Sie auch weiterhin
in Bayern in der Opposition bleiben auch
wenn sie stärker sind als die Freien
Wähler ich bedanke mich bei Katrin Ebner
Steiner für das Interview